luno the fastest easiest way to buy crypto
if you're just getting into bitcoin it's the
perfect place to start guys anna welcome back to
the layah heilpern show powered by icon plus so
as always some quick news for you so bloomberg has
said south korea is the world's leading innovative
economy with icon positioning itself as the
gateway for financial institutions deep by web3
and did solutions now this show is sponsored
by block five so a quick shout out to them
um i use them to add up to 8.6 interest on my usdc
and you can actually get up to 250 dollars um when
you sign up with them so i've left the link
for you in the description and in the comments
and before we bring on my guests a quick shout out
to coinflip so you can actually get 10 off your
transactions with them um with a discount code i
will leave that rolling somewhere in the bottom
now before i bring on my really brilliant guest
today um who i'm sure you guys probably know
who they are already if you are watching on
youtube please don't forget to hit the like button
hit subscribe so you never miss any of
these amazing guests now joining me today
are the names behind the social network
the bitcoin billionaires and of course
the guys behind the crypto exchange gemini it is
of course tyler and cameron how are you doing guys
hey doing great thanks for having us yeah
absolutely pleasure nice to see you cameron nice
to see you too all right so guys firstly thank
you so much for coming on um i'm super excited to
jump straight in because there's been some huge
news this week um you guys are partnering with
um ben mesrick again which is really exciting but
this time you guys are executive producers um of
the anti-social network so talk to us how did this
come about what is it about tyler jonah go for it
first sure we we first met ben about a decade
ago when he wrote the accidental billionaires
which became the movie the social
network and then we reconnected
a couple years ago uh because he
wanted to write a book about bitcoin
which became bitcoin billionaires which were
portrayed in our early journey in in bitcoin and
then recently with the wall street bets game stock
drama of last week he wrote a treatment that uh
mgm picked up this weekend and we're going to
executive produce so that's our history with ben
so what's this gonna look like cameron we'll
come to you what's this gonna look like right
so for those that don't really know what happened
with gamestop explain anti-social network because
that's a bit of a spin-off from the social network
yeah so it's an interesting story basically
um a bunch of people on the wall street bets
subreddit um started buying gamestop which
was a very heavily shorted um stock i think over
like 150 more than the actual amount of shares or
float um so a few hedge funds uh we're
trying to drive this company into the ground
and a bunch of these individual traders which
refer to themselves as d gens and um another other
things other terms or whatever um basically banded
together and uh ran over this hedge fund and i
think the hedge fund lost something like four
or five billion dollars and it was sort of this
triumphant moment where individuals sort of um
stuck it to um the institutions and almost always
historically it's been sort of the other way
around and it was a really interesting moment um
and that's kind of how it all got started i think
the wall street bats forum in reddit has grown
by something like six million users and a lot of
these individuals who trade and and go to gamestop
and believe in the company um but also kind of um
believe that the system in wall street is broken
and and rigged against them so a lot of this is is
really sort of almost out of protest um uh against
the system um and things like that so that's sort
of the the general uh gist of what's been going on
but the whole against the system
so i have a quite an interesting
interesting way of looking at this do you think
this is something which is predominantly kind of
an idea within this online crypto community
because i know i saw you guys on cnbc and you
were sort of putting forward this idea and i think
particularly for tyler it didn't go down so well
yeah well um last week the robin
hood app halted mysteriously halted
the buying of certain tickers of gamestop and
amc but um allowed you to continue to short them
and so people sort of saw that centralized power
saying sort of be platforming you and saying
hey you can't trade these now you can only sell
them you can't buy them so that's where a lot
of the outrage was that the little guy um was
being told like hey now you you can't trade this
and i think it got a lot of people thinking
about um uh crypto bitcoin and defy because
there is no de-platforming in bitcoin there's no
de-platforming in crypto there's no call to make
and whether it's a clearing house calling
or a hedge fund calling a clearing house
um there's no one there you can't make a call
to the clearinghouse is the blockchain uh crypto
settles uh atomistically in in real time and
you can't call the blockchain and say hey um
risk concerns increase margin um stop that going
through and so the decentralized nature of bitcoin
and crypto that power really came to center stage
at the same time that um how so few hands control
centralized finance and a few people can tell um
you know robin hood or all their users now you
can't actually trade this and so that's where
a lot of the outrage and confusion but also
the light would shine onto the the centralized
system and how few people actually run it and the
establishment makes uh the decisions for you so
that was really the big eye-opener for for me and
a lot of people um the whole world frankly last
year last week except for the guys on cnbc though
yeah no they they were they were shocked
and dumbfounded that i might suggest that
um someone may have leaned on on
robinhood to shut down trading on one side
which we know actually now has been the case the
clearing organizations did lean on robin hood
and it's unclear um who leaned
on the clearing organizations and
the other element that makes this particularly
sort of nefarious feeling and maybe there's a good
innocent answer but we haven't heard it is that i
kind of understand if if you say hey we gotta shut
down trading on both sides so you can't you can't
buy but you also can't sell yes um and then if
there's uh a margin issue or a reserves issue then
you shut down margining so you allow people to
uh buy and sell without margin so a you could just
shut it all down right so it's not just the buying
and selling you shut both you freeze the entire
stock or if you're not going to do that you freeze
margin but you allow people to trade with full
reserves so if they actually have the cash on hand
then they can make the buy as opposed to borrowing
so the idea that the it's the clearinghouse's
fault doesn't explain to me why you shut
down one side of the trade and not the other
um and uh and why you wouldn't shut down
just margin but allow fully funded full
reserve trades to go and so that's definitely
that adds to the nefarious feeling around it
the feeling that the goal post was changed
that the the playing field's not level and once
the retail investor starts to win the uphill
battle they just tilt the playing field
you know even more to make it steeper and harder
so all of those whether they're optics or whatever
maybe they just have terrible pr um and they
don't know how to manage this crisis but they've
been through a lot of crises before not quite this
level but there's been a lot of stuff in the press
about you know the commission free trading
which really isn't free um the gamification
of these platforms it encourages people to um
trade and invest in ways that they maybe don't
fully understand um so they've dealt with like
some headwinds and pressed before but like the
fact that we still don't really know and people
have been digging for answers and it's almost
a week later um that's hard to understand yeah
and it seems like the the questions aren't being
asked a ton i mean i think uh elon interviewed
uh the founder on clubhouse but i i'm not seeing
sort of uh and maybe i'm just not seeing it in
my feed or wherever of journalists like running
up the chain okay robin hood if it wasn't you then
it was a clearinghouse who in the clearing house
and and let's get some answers here right it's a
very opaque um system with like endless plausible
deniability and it all really underscores
the the the sort of the importance of defy um
the permissionless nature and that's really where
it's all going i mean gamestop was this this
battle on the turf of wall street in the system
robin hood's just an extension of that system
it's a horse with a better saddle it's got fancier
marketing at the end of the day it's beholden to
the system we saw firsthand it's like playing um
a football game and uh american football and and
um you know one team's not allowed to score
for a quarter hey you can only play defense
you can liquidate your position but you cannot
offensively score um and go play that game
and defy doesn't have that movable goal
post and and that's where it's gonna go it's
it's sort of it's less about hey let's go fix this
system that's that's not transparent and you see
it with money too right the the the fed in
the u.s it's a it's a board i think of 12
governors making decisions behind a door in
a closed room we have no idea and then they
come out and say hey aha we we've done this
it's like the wizard of oz and and people are
are waking up and so gamestop was it wasn't just
about a ticker or a price um it was really this
awakening of like wait a second this is just the
system and what is what alternatives do we have
and that's how we get to and that's why we've
been excited about bitcoin and ethereum for
um the better part of eight years and you know
we're just seeing more and more reasons um
for for them and the need yeah i mean i think i
for one hope that this is um you know one of those
things that will wake people up to cryptocurrency
i think the whole corona virus the whole printing
of money is sort of one thing that's been able
to wake people up a little bit um i hope this
is another thing especially um for you know gen
z but in terms of the movie that's coming out
can you give us an idea of how it's gonna look i
know it's still super early days but what kind of
angle are you taking and also in terms of key
players how are you going to do this because
there aren't any you know actual faces behind the
reddit group it's not like you know social network
where you had yourself you had mark zuckerberg
you had eduardo these were all personalities
um how are you gonna do this yeah that's a really
great question and and ben um mesrick is is super
talented maybe one of the best people in the world
of sort of teasing and pulling the story out when
we met with him a couple years ago about bitcoin
he had read in the in the new york times that we
were had become bitcoin billionaires he's like
wait a second okay i need to reach out to these
guys and talk to them and see what they're up
to and we sat around for like an hour or two and
kind of told them what we had been up to and he's
like i think there's a story here and we're like
are you sure i don't know it seems like
pretty normal like you know day-to-day
for us um and then he kind of came back and was
like hey i think this is like actually really
really interesting and these are the different
things i want to talk about and he's a masterful
storyteller in that regard and so he's actually
already talking to the mods on the wall street
bets boards he's talking to people in hedge funds
and finance and and he's sort of very good at
getting to sources and and teasing out and pulling
out the story and then building a cohesive uh sort
of three act um uh narrative that that's really um
built purpose-built sort of for for the movie so
um there's gonna be people like roaring uh the
roaring kitty um youtuber um who's hilarious
and actually has been talking about gamestop for
like well over a year he's like sort of built
for for movie and and this kind of medium and
there's other characters like that along the way
so i think it's going to be incredibly colorful
and it's going to be sort of uh uh you know the
the internet like it's going to capture the
zeitgeist of of this movement and the internet
and all these different individual sort of this
this bee hive like um coming together um so i
i i think it's gonna be really interesting yeah i
saw ben tweeted he was like i'm gonna put all of
your tweets in the movie it's gonna be really just
sort of showcasing um you know what all of this is
really um yeah go for it the beauty part about
this is that so much unfolded out in the open
the wall street bets channel right anyone can see
that the twitter the area that people can't see is
the decision-making of robin hood the calls or
the inquiries into the clearinghouse or from the
clearinghouse to robin hood the decision-making of
melvin capital what happened in melbourne capital
what happened at citadel that side is completely
private um and obfuscated from the public but the
wall street bets and the twitter and roaring kitty
um all that's out there you know so so that that's
that that part's easy to sort of bring to the
silver screen right yeah i think it's going to
be really interesting to see how this happens and
if you know you guys and ben are able to sort of
really put forward the lack of transparency
there i think it will play an amazing case um
there's there's such a uh crazy intersection i
mean elon musk is a big part of the story right
yes i'm so excited sent it uh to the moon and so
there's sort of that that parallel uh intersection
with elon like why is elon involved in the game
style or why is he talking about it um and i think
you know mark cuban has talked about it we talked
about it um there's there's so many more done
what's up i think he just put 700 million into
amc i just saw by the way before we went live
700 million who put that in i think or maybe i'm i
think i lost 700 000 because uh the stock was was
halted so he bought at the top and sold at the
bottom so he's upset that he lost money because
robin hood and vlad decide vlad the stock impaler
decided that hey you can't you can no longer um
yeah vlad the stock impeller i think that was
elon musk named for him when he interviewed him
um but it's fitting but yeah because you know um
vlad woke up or someone woke up and said you can
no longer buy this dave lost almost a million
dollars yeah i think it's terrible yeah um and
and the thing is um you know the social network
when it came out in 2010 um is really the first
movie about sort of modern um the modern
college experience the modern tech experience
entrepreneurship startups uh when we were at
harvard um i think computer science might have
been like the least popular major um because it
was in you know the dot-com bubble it happened
in the late 90s early 2000s people are still
sort of reeling from that and i think you know
this story sort of has the opportunity to be sort
of the first modern story about like the internet
and the subcultures and the subreddits and all all
those um different uh you know elements out there
and and capturing the time and it's it's about 10
years later and it's sort of like the timing lines
up every 10 years there's this like new zeitgeist
and i think it has the potential of capturing
uh so much that's going on right now with like the
issues of centralization and decentralization the
movements of bitcoin and things like that so it's
going to be um incredibly colorful maybe more so
than the social network oh i think so i think it's
going to be far more colorful as you put it but i
want to talk about the social network so i do want
to go back a bit to how we all first heard of the
wink of os twins it was obviously because of the
movie it was because of facebook so you guys are
kind of seen initially um as the bad guys because
you guys were the jocks and mark was you know the
nerd so we sort of felt sorry for him but after
time that narrative obviously began to change
so i do want to hear about that moment um that
iconic moment when you found out that mark had
potentially stolen your idea yeah look it was it
was a very convenient narrative to pittus as sort
of the the jocks the establishment um the bad guys
um the guys in karate kid who were cobra kai um
i just started watching that on netflix and it's
pretty pretty awesome um show highly recommend it
um but yeah like it was a convenient like 80s
narrative sort of fast forward we kind of now see
facebook as the establishment i think um history
or time has a way of sort of the truth surfacing
um and and i think a lot of folks were like wait
a second you guys can't be like jocks and and idea
guys and executors and tech guys that's not for
you that's for the fuzzy nerd people over here
and it's like wait a second no that's just not
the way the world necessarily has to work um
and when we first read about the facebook we
read about it in harvard crimson in february of
like 2004 and we're like this sounds like our
site this sounds like are there more than one
mark zuckerberg at the school because it is
a twin like what what it was an incredibly
uh surreal experience and kind of um blindsided
us and really was just a huge punch like in the
gut we were just like what what just went on and
then we just basically had to figure out what
the right path forward was um we went to the the
university president uh larry summers at the time
uh there's a scene that's pretty pretty hilarious
in the social network uh he's got his uh shoes
up on the on the on the table he's incredibly uh
dismissive scornful all of that's true um spot on
none of that in fact uh if anything they they
downplayed it um he's incredibly unhelpful
um and we were sort of uh confused because the
university has like an ethics uh code and a
rule of conduct and we're like well gee okay you
guys don't really care about any of this stuff
interesting okay we were sort of uh mistaken on
that but he did say hey go to the courts that
was his advice and and we did and you did that
was really our only um uh uh course of action
there and uh you know it took uh many years um but
we got to a place you know and then moved on and
and really the last 10 years have been all about
crypto i mean look uh facebook is obviously grown
a lot it's it's a it's it's has its um issues or
you know there's a lot going on but we're really
focused on on bitcoin ether um and cryptocurrency
in general and we started gemini um
our exchange gemini.com um in in 2014 it was sort
of an idea in 2014 we launched in 2015 once we got
our trust company license and we're just basically
trying to create a platform where it's super easy
for you to buy sell and store and now lend your
crypto to earn yield um and make like a platform
that's super simple because i think a lot of
people like once they sort of buy into bitcoin
or ethereum they're like i get it i understand the
story but how do i get it and do it in a safe way
when we first got in in 2012 uh we there
wasn't a safe way we took on a ton of risk
had to build our own cold storage system which
is chronicled in the bitcoin billionaire's book
it's a really fun uh chapter i think people tend
that really resonates with people they they often
like cite that um that uh that chapter and we
basically built gemini to kind of help solve that
problem and mainstream this movement yeah i
want to focus on gemini but before we do because
bitcoin came first i want to do it i want to
do it we're going to do it and we're going to
talk about the the new earn feature but before
gemini you guys bought bitcoin in ibiza so i do
just kind of want to talk about that because it's
totally random and actually it's really important
because what what's really unique with you guys
is that you're at the center of two of the biggest
um revolutions that we've had in the last decade
right so you had facebook which kind of sparked
social media and then now bitcoin which has been
a huge revolution so how did you stumble across
bitcoin yeah so we found love in a hopeless place
um literally we were we were in ibiza um in the
summer of 2012 on vacation we're not looking for
the next big thing somebody from brooklyn actually
recognized us from the social network the movie
and said hey you know started talking we started
chatting and he said have you guys thought about
virtual currency or bitcoin and we hadn't at the
time like tell me more um so we started chatting
about it and at first it sounded um a little crazy
and then we took a shot of tequila and it started
to make a lot more sense and uh we we connected
uh stateside and um started reading up on on
bitcoin and we're really blown away by what we
saw as like a money network a monetary network um
and money really is the ultimate social network
when you think of it when you think of why gold
has value it's because people are willing to
accept it and they believe in it they have faith
in in in that um instrument and and bitcoin
uh really has a lot of the similar properties
and we sort of said wow this feels like it could
be the next big thing it's either complete [ __ ]
or or you know very binary or could be incredibly
enormous a incredible uh network and invention
and and just the the the risk of sort of not
being a part of it that fear was was huge we
have to kind of figure this thing out and we
started talking to bitcoiners and getting really
um they were so passionate like the energy and
it felt like there's this little secret hiding in
plain sight that we had stumbled upon and and we
couldn't like get enough of it so we we did the uh
the the crazy thing of uh jumping in uh you know
just into the deep end and buying a lot you know
buying a ton and i'm not sure we even at the time
could totally articulate it because bitcoin's
kind of a complex thing but we felt it we knew we
knew like this this is going to be um incredible
and in that buying process we started to think
about okay well how do we kind of help build this
industry as opposed to also you know investing is
one thing but you also want to be we're builders
at heart we love building things and so what can
we build what should we build what do we need to
build to make this thing um really go mainstream
yeah and obviously you went and you built gemini
so i do want to talk about gemini a bit because
um you guys are you know you just you do
everything properly obviously and you know you've
got the regulation in place and i think you never
listed xrp is that right because of the the lack
of clarity that's correct yeah so so with that
in mind um you know you're obviously very much
in line with everything so what are your thoughts
on regulation and sort of mass adoption and this
space moving forward do you think regulation is
going to be really necessary and how is gemini
going to sort of work with these new developing
regulations and laws yeah so our belief is that
thoughtful regulation builds really healthy
vibrant strong markets it's also the only way to
um build a bridge between um your money and your
bank now and getting into crypto so gemini was not
a regulated new york trust company with money
transmission licenses in almost 50 states um if
we didn't have an e-money license in the uk if we
didn't have a license in singapore uh pending then
it would be very difficult for you to go to your
bank and wire money or convert it into bitcoin
ether crypto um because we have those licenses
because we've worked with regulators to become
regulated and help them shape and educate them
on the regulation to build the right regulation
you can open an account with gemini you can
wire your money to our account and you can
buy uh bitcoin ether you can keep it with us
you can store it but you can also withdraw it
um right into your wallet into another exchange
let's say coinbase into a d5 protocol like ave
um and so that is the only way we know how to sort
of link up these two worlds and build that adapter
bridge portal so that people can come over um
people should be aware also um while we're on
the topic of robin hood um and dogging on them
a little bit is that when you buy crypto there
it's actually stuck in jail it's a walled
garden so if you buy bitcoin at robinhood
um it's actually stuck there and
you have to sell it into cash
wire the cash out and then wire the cash back
to gemini by bitcoin the problem with that
other than the friction in the inconvenience
is that when you sell your bitcoin exposure
in robinhood it's a taxable event so um it's
very efficient inefficient and costly for you
to actually go in and out of bitcoin um and
it really kind of destroys your ability to
huddle long term if you want to but um kind
of going back to the original question um
we think thoughtful regulation is the best way to
get as many people into uh bitcoin crypto ethereum
defy um and so that's why we we dedicated the last
now six years of our lives to to um uh working on
that and building gemini with that yeah i mean i
was speaking to raul powell about um regulation
and he was sort of saying that if we want it to
be if we want bitcoin to be the next big thing if
we want it to be this store of value that you know
outperforms gold and so on regulation is necessary
for the big names to get in like you know we saw
with microstrategy um otherwise you know it just
stays as something that people use within the
community and it is what it is um but i guess you
know we all sort of want it really to take off you
know we spin it against the gold narrative and one
day once everybody's in right gemini might look
different um it could have more of a decentralized
clearing mechanism that involves the blockchain
or whatnot so um we're a living breathing organism
a company like any good company you're always
looking to disrupt yourself you know you're not
just placing on what's your current stack look
like um or protecting your franchise business
you're looking out on the horizon like what's the
next frontier and we may have different stacks
right now we're a sex or a checks or whatever
you want to call it a centralized exchange um
and we could have you know different stacks
for different customers depending on where the
market evolves and speaking of gemini developing
you've obviously just launched the earn feature
so tell us about this and how does it compare
to what blockfy have what celsius network have
crypto.com yeah so we um we just increased
what we call the money verbs at gemini
um so buy and sell are two verbs right two actions
you can take and then store um and now earn and
so you can lend your crypto and earn yield or
earn interest on that um i think our rates are
are really competitive um but also like our
trust brand and the fact that we're a new
york trust company everything we're doing is
regulated and so you sort of have that layer
of trust over um the the the offering which
really doesn't i think exist anywhere else
um there are other places offshore that are
unregulated that um you know will offer yield
but uh buyer beware because there's no recourse
um and things like that so we think i mean that's
that's like the the number one question i tend
to get is people want to understand like what is
the safety and security here behind it because you
you buy bitcoin or whatever you want to hodl it
you also want to protect that value and you want
to make sure that you're protecting it and it's
safe in yield and we think we've built a really
great product uh that that helps consumers get
yield but also protects them and things like
that and i think we're the only people in new
york state for example big state um that offers it
in a regulated manner so uh we're really excited
about it and we're gonna be rolling it out to
other parts of the world as well and adding more
assets to it uh coming in the next couple weeks so
where is it available right now uh i believe we're
in all 50 u.s states right now uh so basically all
of america um looking at other international areas
um more assets and uh and so it's it's sort of
in a we're in like a soft launch mode i think
next week it gets opened up to everyone um the
the numbers are pretty staggering um in terms
of like the uptake um i won't disclose them right
this moment other than saying that um it it's been
really phenomenal to watch uh the other thing that
we got the the other recent product launch that
this brings to mind is our credit card offering
where you can basically swipe your credit card and
earn crypto uh rewards back people uh are going
crazy for that they're really excited because um
it's a behavior that we all do and instead of
getting silly rewards points or airline miles
you can now actually invest and save as you spend
your your cash which is quickly becoming trash
because of all the money spending um and it turns
consumers into into investors and that's that's a
really cool uh element and it's a great way
to access crypto in an easy to understand
manner because one of the other questions that
i often get asked is like well when do i buy how
do i time it how much should i buy and this
takes those questions and thought out of it
um where you just sort of can kind of do it on an
ongoing basis yeah i think it's really exciting
just to sort of see how this space is moving and
i really like the idea that you know you can earn
you said you can earn was it bitcoin back you
said right you can get your cash back in bitcoin
excuse me any um any crypto that we support
i think we have about okay rick's right now
um and so you could choose bitcoin you could
choose ethereum you could choose uh litecoin
whatever token that we support i think that's
great because i i use a lot of different cards um
because they all do different things just slightly
differently and um i don't like to get my cash
back in their own token um because it devalues
unfortunately really quickly um but i guess
especially when you can't fly anyway right right
exactly you know um yeah so if this pandemic
continues then at least we get our bitcoin or
ethereum back but speaking of ethereum you guys
are super bullish on eth um which is really cool
to see so i'd love to know why what is it um
because obviously you know bitcoin is sort of
the heart and soul of this but it's quite cool
to hear that you're into eth so whoever wants to
go for it yeah we've been long-term eth hodlers um
pretty much since inception and we're actually
the first regulated exchange in the world to list
ether i think in april of 2016. so we've been
big supporters of the project for a long time
and if bitcoin is sort of the store of value like
think of it as digital gold that's filling that
quadrant of money um or utility um ethereum is
really this like decentralized operating system
where you can build apps or smart contracts or
really whatever you want and to run these apps
or contracts you need ether so it's sort of
like the digital oil of this operating system
and it powers a lot of this stuff and so as more
and more apps get sort of built on top of ethereum
then there's greater demand for for ether and so
we're seeing an explosion in decentralized finance
right now where people are building lending
applications and exchanges or decentralized
exchanges like called dexes and people are uh you
know basically re-architecting financial services
on the ethereum blockchain and um i think you
know people are are naturally very bullish about
the prospects because when you think about the
possibilities of of uh operating system they're
sort of limitless the kind of what you could build
and we we have no idea i mean a year from now
the things that are going to be coming out
um we're going to look back and say wow i
can conceptualize that um it's this sort of
cambrian explosion of of ideas and and and
development and so when we think of the value
of bitcoin and we actually wrote a piece
on on uh the case for five hundred thousand dollar
bitcoin we published it in august um it's on our
website winklevosscapital.com and we basically
said look we think bitcoin overtakes gold for
these reasons if you look at the market cap of
gold it's like an eight nine trillion dollar
uh market cap and so we backed into 500 000 a
coin i think bitcoin was trading at 13 000 in
in august when we published it's now at 37 000. um
it's it's making progress but it's still like 15
times off of where we think it can be within the
next decade that's sort of the time within the
deck the next day it's been a decade it could be
as fast as five years um but we're very confident
that within the decade um but ethereum is sort
of if you take the operating system of ios and
window and linux sort of is all of that potential
or cloud computing it's all of that potential and
it's really hard to put a ceiling or a framework
on creativity you know in what that means um
so how do you value that um well i can tell you
that at fifteen hundred dollar ether today it's
sixteen hundred dollars but yeah the all-time
high was breached i think um a day or two ago
and that was reached three years ago and
the amount of work that's gone on and the
the development and maturity of the network in
the past three years you're looking at ethereum
basically at its all-time high um it feels like
really undervalued uh where it currently is um
bitcoin is twice what it's all time or close to
twice its all-time high of three years ago so
we think there's a lot of value there and um loved
sort of the endless possibilities and nature of it
so i take it then you guys are quite for the whole
d5 movement um because i think although people are
pro eth sometimes a lot of people sort of think
defy is just a shambles um what's your take
so we're definitely pro defy we've listed uh
dozens of d5 tokens on gemini um we're really
uh very supportive it's early days right and and
and uh it's in the process of sort of building
the building blocks or the money legos and
putting them together and re-architecting um uh
centralized finance um and there's risk right
it's not the most user-friendly experience
there's there's definitely risk some projects will
will fail spectacularly and some some of them will
be incredibly successful um and so it's new and
and that has to be sort of the lens at which you
approach it but i think what's happening the the
foundational start of it is is really um amazing
and and it doesn't compete with bitcoin that's
like one of the big things and unfortunately um
you you see is people become maxies or maximalists
and they're like only bitcoin or only ethereum or
only you know whatever token and it doesn't
have to be the case because they're solving
totally different things and you know we we
often talk about like if you look at sport
right the world's best gymnast in the world looks
a lot different than the world's best bodybuilder
they're both phenomenal at what they do but a
gymnast wouldn't be you know a great bodybuilder
and and vice versa they'd be really horrible at
each other's sports um and uh and so they're doing
different things and there's room for a couple
of amazing projects another really cool one
that we're bullish and investors in is file coin
it's creating this decentralized uh data storage
layer so you think of um storing your files on
on dropbox right well there's a potential that
dropbox says you know some point hey we don't
really want to store your files sorry we're
closing you down um uh and there's censorship
resistant uh risks um and and i think that um
they're also not built to like interact with
blockchain so if you're building a decentralized
app on ethereum that needs to store data um
you know file coins a really interesting place
to store encrypted data and the token is is the
filecoin is the token or the asset of that network
um that's a really cool project it's not
competing with bitcoin it's not helping
ethereum in fact it's creating synergies and
things like that so we don't prescribe to the
sort of the maximalist philosophy we like looking
at projects are they solving like unique problems
what are the teams behind this what's like the the
genesis the origin story and then going from there
um there's probably not going to be hundreds and
hundreds um but there's not going to be one or two
or three there's going to be a number of really
exciting crypto projects i i'd also say that um
you know whether or not you believe in d fire
works it actually has a chance of solving the
problems that we saw last week with robin hood
right centralized finance the fact that all of
the power is held in so few hands um d5 has got a
shot at completely re-architecting the financial
infrastructure and reimagining and rebuilding wall
street in a decentralized permissionless credibly
neutral uh manner and i think that's that's a huge
idea and there's tremendous promise so like i have
to be our cheerleader of that yeah i'm totally
with you um you know people also sort of look
at africa as a sort of um a let's say an example
of where this stuff could become really useful
where they don't have the financial infrastructure
that we have in the west and they sort of skip um
you know entire revolutions um i just think with
d5 i think it just needs more time it needs more
credibility it needs more work and you know as
we always say think you know we're still early
um but i'm with you i'm so excited to see how it
completely changes things it takes the power back
yeah and also like um if you can't get a loan
right from your board yeah exactly you can't
get a bank account can't get a loan you can
start a business you can't mortgage your house
maybe use that to start a business like so many
people the the decision of your financial future
whether you're not able to prepare uh to create
you know create wealth your family and build a
better like situation for yourself um and your
family is a decision made by a few people at a
bank so that's what i love about the fact of defy
it's like you're interacting with a smart contract
if you if you deposit um the the collateral or
whatever you can you can borrow or you can lend
and smart contracts don't discriminate for
any reason at all computer code is not bias
that's not the case with humans that's
not the case with all these gatekeepers
so i think that's really important a lot of
people um kind of miss that part too maybe
is how democratic and if you literally have a
smartphone um you know in an internet connection
you can all of a sudden get access to credit
access you can save um you know life savings
you have you have basically a bank in in your
pocket and you have the basic tools to create a
better life for yourself to grow your wealth for
yourself your family and your future generations
um and that's just like too big to overlook so do
you guys hold any d5 tokens any coins like link
we're not on the link train uh actually we've
done it a de minimis amount but not um not large
large but uh it's it's a very interesting project
we we support it on gemini uh the link marines
are a very passionate group um it's always fun
interacting with them on twitter yeah for sure
so just quickly back to bitcoin for a sec you
know you mentioned you think it could surpass
gold so what is your general view for bitcoin
and the space do you see it as um you know the
reserve currency do you see it as a day-to-day
payment solution or just as a store of value
um i think store value definitely emergent
you know obviously it's got its work cut
out for it it's still um you know needs to be a
multi-trillion dollar uh uh asset to to sort of
really have arrived in that direction um we're
seeing companies put it on their balance sheet
attacked against inflation with all the
money printing that's happened in covid
um and even really before then um and we
think that there will be some central banks
and governments that like actually start buying
bitcoin and putting it on their balance sheet
and understand the value they they've uh you know
been using gold and buying gold for for many many
many years um we think bitcoin is just around the
corner there um so really exciting and then does
it become sort of this reserve currency of the
internet very very possibly um that it's kind of
where people store their value and then then they
move in and out of bitcoin and other things when
they need to build smart contracts on ethereum
or whatever and then move that value back into
something like you know bitcoin so um we think
it's super interesting and it cannibalizes the the
gold uh that story gets even more interesting
when you look at um how much gold there is in
the universe we wrote about this this summer and
um i think people thought we were a little crazy
that's true but there's there's billions if
not trillions of uh dollars of gold emotional
sitting on asteroids floating around this planet
um i think elon musk and nassau they've already
got a mission um to explore uh a particular
asteroid i forget what the name of the mission is
psyche okay so that's that ship has
already left literally physically
yeah it's much right and so this idea of putting
a probe on an asteroid and starting to potentially
investigate what's actually in it and potentially
mine it um it's not sci-fi it's it's not out there
it's it's it's truly it's probably within the next
25 years and this idea that gold is scarce it's
really just because the technology hasn't been
there it's been like an access to space problem
we've barely sort of scratched the earth look
at oil uh the us is now a net exporter of oil
um not thought possible 15 years ago and then
fracking technology came about and we're now
pulling out tons of oil and um we're literally
selling it to other countries so uh yeah we think
the gold story is not good long term um and
and that sort of further highlights the need
for for bitcoin which is a truly fixed asset
the only asset of its kind in the observable
universe more demand cannot will not uh increase
supply and that's that's an amazing thing
yeah i think uh i think i made a video um maybe
a few a few months ago about there being gold on
asteroids and i definitely got the same response
like people thought i was absolutely nuts
that's just insane yeah one thing is i
recently read an investor letter from a
very uh blue chip wall street fiduciary firm um
that is in um uh in bitcoin um and they talked
about uh bitcoin or gold mining on asteroids
so it's happening you're just an early adopter
like us it's like it's classic right when we
got into bitcoin and started talking about it
people ridicule laugh you know make fun of and
now all of a sudden you become you're the smartest
person in the room and it's the same thing with
um mining gold on on asteroids it's like that
famous quote i don't know it's uh ascribe to
gandhi first they ignore ignore you then they
laugh at you then they fight you then you win it's
the same thing for every entrepreneur um or or
actually frankly a good investor is that you sort
of look crazy um and people sort of ridicule you
but then all of a sudden your thesis proves right
and you know you are the smartest person you you
you can't have consensus when you're talking about
the future or the frontier or something innovative
or forward thinking you have to be alone and
be willing to be alone on your thinking there
um and so that's just part of like when people
disagree or sort of have that reaction i kind of
feel like i know i'm onto something yeah i want to
just like quickly delve into this a little bit um
because like i said you guys were at the forefront
of the two biggest revolutions some people might
have said before you guys stumbled onto bitcoin
that the first one was just circumstantial
having been at harvard and so on um but but it's
obviously not and you guys are doing incredible
stuff um what would you say i guess is the key
to it's a hard question i appreciate that so
what did you say the key is to sort of
entrepreneurship and um you know really
going for something and spotting that that needle
in a haystack i guess or the diamond in a rough
yeah i mean i think that that it's a it's a
great question and i think that um creativity
is so important and i think a lot of people
get sort of pushed off their authentic selves
and they kind of lose that that spark and and
they sort of get pushed off of of what they
really think is cool and they go end up like
sort of going down paths that are pretty
straightforward and in the box so i think like um
really sort of staying true to your own creativity
is really the only way to be competitive and
build in that infinite game um where there's just
unknowns um i mean when we started gemini bitcoin
was really like the only like thing out there
um we didn't we couldn't have predicted a lot of
what's happened and yet we knew if we built like a
a cool t a great team brilliant people we're just
gonna find cool things to do here and so that's
part of it um it's incredibly sort of uh stressful
and hard work and very narrow um like you you have
to give up things you will give up a ton to
do it and and like what have you guys given up
um just uh a lot of like time time yeah
like your own personal time right you know
sometimes you're you're pulling just uh you're
working non-stop through weekends for months
but but it doesn't feel like you're working
that's the key right that's why um it's a
good idea for us to be entrepreneurs but if it
feels like a sacrifice too much or too much time
um then it's probably not the right adventure
for you because it is literally one of the
hardest things you can do and take on your life
we trained for 15 years to become olympic athletes
and that was a very difficult difficult pursuit
um starting a company is in the same realm
there are differences um but you give up a lot
of or you know ostensibly give up a lot of things
but it doesn't feel like that to us and that's the
key is it doesn't feel like we're working but if
we punched our hours we're never not working you
know we never it's it's not a nine to five you
check in check out um always on twitter always
on slack always doing things whether it's eleven
o'clock at night one o'clock at night six in the
morning depending on the day people ask like are
you do you get a you know do you wake up early
well it depends on the morning depends on what the
mission calls for sometimes i'm up at 4 00 4 30 in
the morning five in the morning and some mornings
i'm up at eight or nine um some nights i'm in bed
at 9 30 just totally exhausted some some you know
for whatever reason you're up till one or even
later so it's literally you have to be able to to
to take that on and adjust and and smile while
you're doing it and love it and realize that
you'd be miserable doing anything else you'd be
miserable working for the man you'd be miserable
trying to become partner at the investment bank or
the law firm and some people love that they love
that certainty they're like i want that linear
path from where i am right now to where i'm going
to be in 20 years that is comforting to me i don't
want to swim with the risk of other people's money
and employing a lot of people um and building
a company um i love that risk it doesn't feel
like risks i sleep very well at night um even
though you know other people might look at me
and like you're you're carrying the weight
of the world and juggling all this stuff so
you got to find what's the right adventure for
you i mean for us it's building a company yeah i
mean i can i can actually totally relate because
i i used to work mad hours as a journalist for
china's global tv network and i'm talking like six
in the morning until midnight no weekends so that
that obviously builds up and i hated it and i
was absolutely miserable um whereas now sometimes
i'm working even more definitely working on the
weekends given we're unlocked down here in the uk
and it's fun it doesn't feel like work because
you know you're building your own dream
um so it makes sense and i think i think i saw
um somebody tweet something like entrepreneurs
are the only people that would sort of leave a
a job just to work more hours that's a good um
um but it's really it's it's i think work is is
that one of those funny words that like implies
like an arduous task and and i think when you're
doing what you love it tends to be more play and
you're in flow and and it it doesn't feel like
work and i think that's kind of the key here
um and and just finding like that that passion
in that area where it doesn't feel like work
and you're willing to put in as much time as it
takes and probably you know tons more than if
you're just working at a normal job so and i think
also figuring out like what what drives you like
what is what is your purpose your mission your why
um and that's a tough thing and it sometimes takes
people a long time to figure that out if they ever
do um some people like love to sort of give back
um they need to be in the peace corps and do that
kind of uh service you know others want to build
or create um so i think finding that is is
is actually really important and we often um
i find it sort of later on um well after we
started creating a company and then we're like
okay now i get it now i know why you're how i got
here but you sort of felt it instinctually but you
didn't actually like write it down on a piece of
paper yeah and the other thing i'd say is it's not
just about hard work right because um elon musk
doesn't have more hours in the day than than uri
it's it's also about like obviously there's going
to be hard work but we don't want to celebrate
that in in itself right um it's about building
great teams it's about creating leverage through
great teams it's about delegating decentralizing
decision making building a culture of innovation
so you're just not coming up with only ideas it's
leveraging through scale through code through
technology through all these things that allow
the same people with the same amount of hours in
their day to have a dramatically different input
on the other side um so it is hard work it's it's
going to be a challenge but also it's not just
as simple as like it's not the pursuit isn't
banging your head against the wall right it's
it's working smart working with leverage um to
build something really great that's what really
separates um a good company from a great company
yeah i think smart work is an important one hard
work means nothing without smart work but just a
personal question for both of you um so what's it
like kind of going through this jungle of life and
sort of having each other right so from college
from dealing with facebook you know business
together you know passing in ibiza together to
building all these things together what's it
like to literally have each other you know because
you're not tackling this on your own which i think
is insane really cool yeah it's awesome i mean
you have like a co-founder like built in and we
we so i'm left-handed tyler's right-handed so we
do actually yeah that's amazing mirror image twins
and uh we we have different styles um but we have
obviously like a shared set of values um and so
we're not sitting around ratifying each other all
day long we're actually challenging each other
and being thought partners um and calling [ __ ]
or or offering like constructive feedback um it's
gotten more constructive as we get older you know
but sometimes when you're younger years like ah
you know um but the point being is is we're we're
teammates and we've been teammates for a long time
whether it's in the rowing arena athletics um
in litigation founding a company um and it's
really exciting because we sort of have different
points of views um and and so i think it's worked
really well we're not sort of the same person
that would be really boring and we'd probably
make bad decisions because we'd both be kind of uh
you know self ratifying each other and things like
that and i think there's we've created that space
where we can have really healthy disagreement
and and build you know um strategy around that
so um it's been it's been really really great
what are your thoughts tyler how's it been
having cameroon with you this whole time
i thought that was the point of having a twin
brother you can just answer no never yeah
so to bring it to crypto like um in terms of
values like foundationally on unlike layer one
we're the same right but as you go up the stack
we have different preferences um but what's key
the number one thing you gotta pick is value
alignment you know what like your ideas of
integrity character honesty truth those things
you've got to get right with your your partners
your employees um the next sort of layers like
abilities um horsepower raw horsepower like
values abilities are hard to change and they're
kind of fully baked by the time you're an adult
skills are the easy things to change or learn
like we can take some with good values great
abilities at gemini and almost no skills and give
them the skills teach them the skills and in fact
it's sometimes better because experience is
just another word for like bad assumptions
or um like poor skills or skills we want to
like d train because um this is crypto it's
a frontier everything's different new so you got
to get the values alignment and then you want that
respectful discourse you want that disagreement
because that's how great ideas are made is the
sort of like respectfully butting heads it's
not consensus of a committee um so we very much
um followed that in our relationship i might
you know turn on a song or something and
like oh that's a good song and cameron's like i
don't really like that like that's great you know
that's yeah we can argue like why do you think
that this way um well i think this is the problem
with the guitar line or you know the the lyrics
or the sound or the tone or whatever the pitch
um so we can kind of go back and forth and that's
just like it's intellectual sparring you know
we're like uh intellectual jogging partners you
want to surround yourself by those people where
you have that space um and grace to challenge
each other and always hire people smarter than you
that's rule number one a lot of people like
it's crazy but on ego they want to be like
key person narcissistic system you just want
to like have a pluses around you and you want
like people are more successful smarter better
looking whatever um because it just levels you up
yeah absolutely what do they say you are the sum
of the five people we spend the most time with
um but guys just finally what are you doing next
what's the vision for gemini what can we expect i
would say one of the the coolest uh things that
we're really excited about is nft non-fungible
tokens arden collectibles so we actually bought a
platform uh niftygateway.com which is now a gemini
gemini family and um we relaunched a platform
i think in march of of 2020 and it's really
been growing like a weed and really exciting
there's um some amazing artists and content on it
and these are you know these are pieces of
art that are verifiable and they live on the
blockchain and we think that's really the
next frontier of like art and collectibles
and um people are getting really excited i mean
the energy again reminds us of like early bitcoin
2012 like well what is this thing and and it's
still like hard for a lot of people to get like
what do you mean like digital art can't i just
take a screen grab of it like how you know what
is this canvas and this medium and and the the the
simple answer is you can go to the louvre and take
a photo of the mona lisa with your iphone doesn't
mean you own the mona lisa or whatever and uh it's
it's we think it's a really exciting frontier and
you're going to hear more and more of it uh we've
had drops from artists and and recording artists
and all kinds of things so it's it's been cool
nice all right well yeah go on and say tyler
yeah and i to say um i'm reading through the
comments um oh i haven't read them yet oh no
uh it's very colorful um a lot of interactions
um but um should we take like a rapper and fire uh
a couple let's definitely do that let's definitely
do it let me have a look through guys if you have
any questions you want to ask then put them in
now because there are like hundreds of questions
right it would be easier if uh people just even if
they had put a question up up top just put it in
right now so we can see it and not have to scroll
all right let's have a look they're coming through
so can we ask layer a question no ask them a
question come on guys they're coming through would
you like okay let's oh gosh here we go hang on
let me get that back will you offer
a debit card uh yes looking into it
okay that's great oh this is going so fast
bear with me with me uh on lake huron uh yeah
maybe that sounds kind of fun old sailor
traitor here we go thoughts on ada cardano
um haven't looked at it close enough yep okay um
let's get some more they're moving really quite
fast it's hard to get them up let's have a look
we've already answered that one here we go when
do you plan on adding more projects to gemini uh
soon we're actually looking at more token listings
right now okay let's have a look there's
more here were you branch to sport nfts
yes and i think we've actually already done
athlete and brand ft's so that's actually already
happened but definitely i mean when i think of
like nfts i think of digital art and collectibles
so everything that's happening in the trading cars
market like the offline meet space like the psa 10
jordan rookies and stuff we're looking
at bringing that on to the blockchain so
definitely do more sports stuff and collabs with
artists and athletes for sure will you ever retire
no because we're not working i retired when
i started gemiini not um no i think what
would we do with ourselves um it's so exciting
that's like saying will i ever get off twitter
i mean all my friends all those my internet
friends i won't i won't have them anymore
um that's that's hard hard to imagine that
future what's tyler and cameron's favorite book
so i'll tell you two books that are i think are
incredible for any entrepreneur recently read no
rules rules it's the netflix book i read hastings
and i think erica meyer but you can google that
if i got that wrong um so good talks about their
culture all the the insights um i really liked
it i found myself nodding a lot like hey this
makes a lot of sense thank you for putting words
uh to that and uh also um every every entrepreneur
should read zero to one by peter thiel
sort of the art of a startup it's a short little
book there's so many pearls of wisdom in there
building a company and startups even angel
investing is very counterintuitive and uh peter
lays this out perfectly so uh i would definitely
those are must reads for sure working as
influential entrepreneurs what is your view on
this modern pc work culture that's a cool one
modern pc work culture i guess you need
everybody we use personal computers every day
all right let's see what else we've got here have
you considered integrating with trainingview.com
for gemini that'd be cool that's interesting
question because we actually have
um and i think we've had an integration with
tradingview for almost a year so you can link
your tradingview account with gemini
and trade all the cryptos that we offer
what are your thoughts on privacy i guess they
mean privacy coins um we list c cash um and we we
turned on shielded addresses i think uh this fall
and we believe there's like a real need for for
privacy uh commercial privacy in in finance um and
transactions and so and i think we were the first
like regulated exchange in the world to
list c cash and maybe still the only one
um the way we did that is we really engaged with
regulators and and work with them to sort of
demystify a lot of this um after all regulators
are are comfortable with cash right and and so
z cash is is very much uh takes sort of the
properties of of uh analog real world meet space
cache to the blockchain and uh a lot of education
but we got it done and we got them comfortable
and we're really excited to support the project
and we think it's a really really good one this
is a great question does spirituality play any
role in your lives and business making decisions
um like horoscopes or something no i
guess well i'm gonna guess they mean more
is a horoscope you know there's some spirituality
there um i think yeah look i think um
when you think of like spirituality and like
following the charm of the universe and like
letting nature sort of author like a path
so to speak um that's like very much uh
in line with with entrepreneurship and building
a company right you you cannot be rigid um and
you cannot cling to things that are no longer
relevant um a lot of times you know we go down
paths and we say oh wait a second that's no longer
makes sense or whatever and you you pull back
and you follow sort of um that serendipity in many
ways that's how we found bitcoin serendipity we
were we were just sort of open and we have this
value at gemini called beginner's mind where
we approach things with the mind of a beginner
we don't bring assumptions from um you know past
experience that can cloud our decision making
because a lot of people saw bitcoin but they
didn't invest they did the opposite they they
either went the other way or they they ridiculed
it um and a lot of those folks have come around
uh since then but that is a really important value
um in how we think about it and is very much i
think uh in like the spirituality domain i think
it's a concept that you find in in uh meditation
and and uh um self-improvement a lot um and so
we think i think i think very much spirituality
is part of what you're doing you have like this
higher calling this mission otherwise just go
work for the man go go do you know another job
right i think joel loved your answer he says thank
you um and what about doge when is that available
can't disclose um but but it's
uh it's a really interesting
vote with the um the audience uh just if you
want to see doge on gemini put a plus one
oh that'll be cool and if you think we
shouldn't put a minus they still put
a plus one with all your success what do
you consider as your greatest achievement
gosh um i think the the the group
of people we've assembled at gemini
um flattered and honored that these folks
took a risk on us took a leap of faith on us
and ultimately trust us to lead them to the moon
so that is definitely one of my top uh if not the
uh top maybe even personal accomplishments or it's
definitely let's put in the professional bucket
yeah i i have to echo that one um you know it's
such a privilege and honor to work with our team
um and a lot of them you know they've taken a
risk on our vision and and both crypto but also
our vision and leadership and uh it's it's really
kind of such a pleasure to to work with with uh
our team and i think that was super amazing um
also rowing in the olympics was was definitely
a super amazing highlight to to represent
our country and and really be part of
uh the olympic movement which is which is really
much more than than just uh sport you know it's
it's it's really a a piece a piece movement um
and that was that was a really exciting journey
um so i'd say those two are are high up there
bit of a cheeky question are you guys um in touch
with anybody from facebook so we're in contact
with dustin uh moscowitz we actually ran into
him we went to burning man in 2013 and 2014.
and i i can't i think it was 2013 we actually
uh randomly serendipitously met um and sort
of kept in touch um so i think he's the only
guy we we are in touch with from facebook i
have a feeling that if we ran into severan
we would be friends um you know given that we went
through sort of similar things a little bit yeah
but i don't know if we've met any of the other um
founding team actually other than mark of course
have you guys ever tried out
nano what do you think of it
i haven't tried it out i don't think how about
you karen a nano nano it's a crypto it's quite an
interesting one no i'll have to check it out all
right there there they've got a great community
um they're gonna be they're really happy that you
uh that you talked about that um any thoughts on
bitcoin cash i think so bitcoin cash is a fork of
of um bitcoin uh came about through a disagreement
in uh transaction speed and throughput um look i
think i think it's great that other you know if
other people want to build other communities and
projects that's awesome i think it's healthier
to sort of not have a lot of disagreement
you know just fork it and go your own way
um haven't stayed that close to the project
but i think um you know look it's it's a
project out there we support it on gemini
for listing and trading so um if you if you
want to buy some you know we offer it will
gemini have their own token like binance
um not anytime soon we have well we have a
stable coin so we have i don't know the binance
token but if it um but we have a stable coin
called the gemini dollar it's a one to one peg
with the dollar i'm also looking at a a question
that says flexa how easy is the relationship in
flexor team is fantastic they they feel
like the gemini team there's so much value
alignment they literally fit in um like a
glove in gemini and we've had an incredible
relationship with them and we look forward to
um doing some great stuff uh continued stuff in
the future for sure all right um i think just
the last one last question gemini earn live
um meaning like is it live the the product i think
that's what they're asking yeah so we we offer uh
it's open to a select group of customers as we
sort of test and roll it out um we just want to
make sure everything's you know it's a new new
product but it it should be open for everyone
within a week or so and we'll message on twitter
follow you know gemiini on twitter um or our blog
or or myself at cameron or at tyler if you want to
uh stay up to date but it'll be out very very soon
um and uh thanks for asking gemini is also
available in portugal uh someone just asked
and also netherlands um and pretty much i think
everywhere in in the european uh economic area or
europe so check it out all right guys thank you so
much for coming on um and i'm sure the audience is
super pleased um about the ama great idea um
thank you so much for coming on it's been so
interesting to learn more about you and understand
you know what's coming up with gemiini next
thanks for having us this was a lot of fun yeah
thanks for having us thank you audience for being
lively and having the great questions and we
look forward to coming on again in the future
not too long from now absolutely
speak soon bye all right see ya